you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast precision medicine
approaches and future of drug
development in oncology presented by dr.
Thomas Metcalfe I am Brenda Kelly camel
a birds and I'll be your moderator for
today's presentation today's educational
web seminars presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
site and provider of virtual events and
webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning we'd also
like to acknowledge the sea and en media
group for help of promote programming
and promotion of the event before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located them lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of our presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in a lower right if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
for obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce dr. Thomas Metcalfe dr.
Metcalf is the head of the science and
technology incubator translational
research Sciences Roche Pharma and the
chair personalized medicine task force
European biopharmaceutical enterprises
he works on projects around the world to
advanced precision medicine we would
like more information about dr. Metcalf
please click on his photo image in the
top right the planners for this event
have stated no relevant financial
relationships however dr. Kevin Davies
did disclose that he is a scientific
advisory board member for pathway
genomics and is on the speaker's bureau
for Harry Walker incorporated and then
neither constitute a conflict please
note that dr.
calf has indicated that he has no
relevant financial relationships
pertaining to this topic please join me
in welcoming dr. Thomas Metcalfe I'll
now turn it over to Tom for his
presentation thank you for the
introduction Brenda and thank you for
the invitation to make this presentation
today got to make a actually a slight
correction to that in terms of discloses
I am a employee and a stockholder than
the rush and that presents a potential
conflict of interest so it's important I
think that you're aware of that and I
like to stress in the content of this
presentation represent my personal views
and not necessarily those of roche so
I'm going to be talking about precision
medicine approaches and the future of
development in oncology precision
medicine approaches are giving us much
greater resolution in the analysis we
can do of genes gene transcripts and
proteins in oncology and this if we
particularly if we were able to link it
effectively via databases with
treatments and treatment outcomes and
related real-world datasets will allow
us to revolutionize the way we treat
cancer and will potentially lead to a
blurring of the lines between clinical
trials in clinical care I want to start
with a short introduction about next-gen
sequencing and its potential impact on
drug development particularly on
oncology next-gen sequencing and similar
molecular tightening technologies are
changing the way the drugs are
discovered and developed the impacts are
many and varied diseases are being
defined in molecular terms with many
diseases being split into micro
indications new targets are being
entered identified leading to new
candidate medicines preclinical models
are being characterized by
next gen sequencing leading to better
drug candidates and its next-gen
sequencing is also being integrated into
drug trials are changing the way we
develop biomarkers companion diagnostics
and personalized medicines next-gen
sequencing is also I'm being actively
used in clinical practice particularly
in rare diseases and oncology are the
cost of the technology is evolving
rapidly and if you look at this chart
you can see that the cost of a
essentially a raw sequence of human
genome has dropped to about the cost of
our $1,000 today and continues to drop
in cost at a rate faster than Moore's
Law so this is a extremely advanced
reduction in the cost of next chance we
connect in sequencing the said next-gen
sequencing and other molecular
technology is a using drug discovery and
development and they extend beyond
genome sequencing so this technology
such as transcript transcriptomics which
allow us to look at and next-gen
sequencing which allowed to look at
point mutations small in dale's copy
number variation and structural
variations which are also allow us to
understand the functional effect of
mutations as I say transcriptomics
particularly using techniques such as
RNA seek allow us to understand
differential expression of transcripts
and also gene fusions alternative
splicing and RNA editing and then Epogen
on genomic approaches also understand
allow us to understand their methylation
histone modification and transcription
factor binding which together give us a
very deep understanding not only
the genes which are being expressed at
any particular time or the the tumor
genome but also the way that tumor
genome is being actively expressed and
to a large extent the the functional
role of those jeans in the tumor and
next-gen sequencing allows us to get a
comprehensive view of the somatic genome
and as I said the transcript phone so
these are the various analyses which are
currently possible to perform on
relatively small samples so as you can
see a biopsy will yield something like
eight ten slides and two slides of these
of each of these biopsy can be used for
RNA for DNA analysis are on a analysis
and protein analysis and this together
with a clinical informatics system can
give us a very rich understanding of how
a tumor is behaving and what it sir what
its makeup is if we look at this in the
context of lung cancer and how it
previously conceptualized lung cancer
looked at lung cancer and our
understanding of the molecular drivers
in cancer as only as recently as 2004
really the only understanding we had was
in terms of cameras mutations and egfr
mutations in cancer and this is advanced
rapidly over the last few years to give
us a much more nuanced understanding of
the molecular drivers in lung cancer
with now about something like sixty five
percent of lung cancers being described
in terms of the molecular drivers which
are which are described here and more
recently as we've introduced Indian
therapies we begin to get an
understanding of how the response to
imminent
is relates to to the molecular makeup of
the the tumor and so this gives us a a
much more complex and rich picture of
the molecular underpinnings of lung
cancer and and makes it's extremely
informational but it makes a treatment
decision making more complex as the
picture of lung cancer becomes more
complex and we're beginning to move now
to a essentially a moving from a
histological view of cancer to something
which is much more molecular in nature
and arriving at a a new molecular
taxonomy of cancer as a as a result of
the use of these molecular profiling
techniques such as XOM seek RNA seek the
use of snip arrays and methylation
arrays and and we're moving from for
instance as looking again at lung cancer
previously we described as squamous like
in or inner in head and neck cancer to
having a much better understanding of
what the molecular drivers are of these
diseases we've also begun to
conceptualize and understand cancers in
a different way as we begin began to get
a deeper understanding of the genomica
complexity underlying many cancers we're
seeing that into patient heterogeneity
means that every patient's lung cancer
is essentially different with no to lung
cancers having exactly the same genomic
make up there may be patterns which have
a high degree of overlap but those are
the same known two will have exactly the
same genomic makeup and we're also
seeing that this much more introd tumor
hejsan a team than we previously thought
with solid tumors made up of many tens
hundreds maybe even more than that
subclones each one genomically different
to the next and this is what allows
genomically diverse tumors to evolve
under therapy with new clones growing
which do not depend on the genomic
alteration which was originally targeted
by one therapy and thus to to escape
therapy by evolution and we began to
understand that this genomic
heterogeneity increases over time and
progresses obviously more rapidly in the
absence of tumor suppressor genes DNA
repair enzymes etc etc and beginning to
see that next generation sequencing is
beginning to be is more routinely in
clinical practice particularly in the US
but also in other geographies and this
is an example of the foundation one
report for solid tumors which is reduced
by foundation medicine which gives an
overview of the patient results the
tumor type the genomic alterations which
have been identified and then the
therapeutic implications of targeted
medicines which may be able to address
the the tumor drivers genomic
aberrations which have been identified
in this particular patients cancer and
this then gives a guide to treating
oncologists about whether or not in
particular therapy will be a program for
this patient also whether there are
clinical trials available which the the
patient can potentially be enrolled in
and there
next-gen sequencing is also being
rapidly corporated into the way we
develop drugs is an example of the long
map trial with a number of some studies
for treatment where patients with
squamous cell lung cancer are enrolled
and the first thing that is done is that
the tumor sample is analyzed and then
patients are allocated to baskets
depending on the molecular subtype and
treated accordingly or enrolled in sub
studies according to the mutations and
molecular aberrations which are present
in their in their cancer so you can see
there five different baskets which are
which are in this one map trial with a
number of sub studies each as I said
with their own basket of molecular
characteristics and and appropriate
treatments for those for those baskets
and as we are beginning to get a more
comprehensive understanding of the
genomic underpinnings of of cancer are
we're beginning to see that the to say a
much more complex picture of cancer is
arising and again this is a this is a
picture of lung cancer and you can see
the enormous number of mutations with an
extremely long tail add to the the
right-hand side of that chart of
relatively rare mutations and this is a
beginning turd to show us that although
there are a number of molecular subtypes
which are relatively dominant on the
left-hand side and there are a there is
an extremely long tail of relatively
rare molecular subtypes as I say as we
moved
add to the the right hand side of this
child and this is beginning to tell us
that for these rarer subtypes it's going
to be quite complex to to develop
clinical trials which are targeted at
these rare subtypes because simply
because of the rarity of the mutation
with maybe patients of a particular
subtype are only representing something
like one or two percent or a very low
percentage of the overall number of lung
cancer patients and if we follow
traditional methods of developing drugs
in these in these rare subtypes it's
going to be extremely challenging to
recruit sufficient patients to to power
a a reasonably sized trial and we're
already seeing those are logistical
difficulties in recruiting patients for
these with these relatively rare rare
subtypes and we having to rethink the
way we develop biomarkers in this area
and also the way that we run trials and
one difference that we are beginning to
apply here or want a different approach
that would beginning to apply is we're
beginning to think that instead of
organizing a study are recruiting
patients with a particular anatomical is
ezel or a a particular subtype of
disease and then screening patients for
particular biomarkers as we recruit for
that trial that it may be best to turn
this paradigm around slightly and as a
first step to to essentially perform a
comprehensive molecular an analysis of a
a much broader basket of or a much
broader
population and patience and then to run
trials accordingly as these baskets fill
up with with patients with those
molecular subtypes and as I said this is
a previous conceptualization of how we
might undermine develop companion
diagnostics or by markers to develop a
personalized healthcare approach you
know in oncology where as you can see on
the bottom half of this chart what we
would like to do is identify a biomarker
relatively early in the process
essentially before we before we enter
into human trials and to start
developing an analytical platform for
this biomarker such that we have a
relatively robust by marker assay which
can then be converted into a companion
diagnostic in the time fair in the time
frame of the drug development and as I
say if you rethink this and you begin to
understand the first of all the
complexity of the genomic alterations
which we're seeing in in many cancers
and you are you realize that are
developing single biomarkers in this way
into compare into companion diagnostics
and becomes extremely difficult and
learn that this conceptualization of
biomarker development and personalized
healthcare can only be really applied to
to those biomarkers which are further to
the right hand side of the chart that I
previously showed you here where they
are essentially dominant biomarkers or
dominant drivers in a particular cancer
type for those rarer alterations further
to the left sorry further to the right
side of this chart we're going to have
to think of different approaches to
developing biomarker assays and
companion diagnostics we're also seeing
that next generation sequencing can be
applied to circulating tumor DNA as a
potential method for monitoring patients
who are on treatment or monitoring for
thee for a rising of certain cancer
types and these liquid biopsies which
are essentially on a blood-based sample
provide a minimally invasive method to
to measure mutant alleles in in cancer
bearing patients we know that
circulating tumor DNA can be found in
the majority of cancer bearing patients
to various degrees and they are pre
screaming liquid biopsy may provide an
up-to-date snapshot into the genetic
landscape of patients entering clinical
trials so the time we can essentially
get a confirmation from the analysis
that we did on the on the diagnostic
biopsy which was which was taken more or
less at our presentation or diagnosis so
that we get a relatively accurate
picture through this pre-screening
liquid biopsy of the the cancer genomic
nature as we enter interview into into
clinical trials and determine it may
give us a more accurate representation
of tumor heterogeneity because we're not
taking a geographically specific sample
from from a tumor and lastly it presents
a very powerful tool for patient
monitoring enabling us to detect
resistant clothes as they arise when a
patient is on therapy and essentially to
be able to monitor whether or not
cancer is escaping from the targeted
therapy which one which has been applied
and therefore adapt therapy before
symptoms occur so we can at a very early
stage in the in the appearance of these
resistant clones we can potentially make
an adaptation of a therapy so if you
look at the the outcomes from next-gen
sequencing base molecular testing and
how this affects clinical trials at the
standards of care if no actionable
alterations are detected then our one
would normally apply best supportive
care or perhaps even a therapy or
potentially rebuy Ops II to try and
identifying actionable rotations if we
have actionable alterations which are
identified so there's a clear
identification of a genomic driver this
can be matched to approved agents from
the same tumor tag so we know that not
all drivers behave the same in different
histologies so obviously if we have the
same tumor type for instance from a lung
cancer this might not behave the same
way as a particular driver in for
instance a gastric cancer so if we have
actionable orientations which are in the
same tumor type we can then use
developed and access agents which are
targeted against these rare mutations if
we have actionable orientations which
which can be matched to investigational
agents from the same tumor that gives us
then a path forward and if we have
actionable orientations which are
identified but no match to but Muhammad
two agents in a different tumor we can
potentially use a registry approach to
to monitor this and if we have
actionable orientations which are can be
matched to
educational agents with a different
treatment we can have to look at running
a clinical trial basket studies or other
similar approaches so using NGS based
analyses and these precision
methodologies to molecular profile so
our patients give us say I think a very
strong tool box to to understand whether
a lot of patients are best treated using
currently available therapies or are
enrolled into clinical trials where
we're investigational agents may be
available which have meta targeted to
the the molecular drivers which have
been identified in their tumor arm there
have been authors who've suggested the
term large-scale randomized clinical
trials are male on no longer me be
practical or ethical ethical in cohorts
which have been divine defined by
next-generation sequencing and this is
principally because we are getting such
a first of all a rich overview of a
particular patient and we are seeing
than no two patients are alike that are
defining cohorts where essentially the
clinical hypothesis is that all the
patients in this cohort are essentially
the same and then testing a therapeutic
regimen which is based upon how this
hypothesis um as I say we are seeing now
that every patient is essentially
different so that it may be time for us
to to move beyond this hypothesis that
are that we have a cohort where all the
patients for the for the base that all
the assumption is that the all the
patients in that cohort are essentially
the same on this Manor no longer be true
and
are how we would proceed with these one
person trials or end of one trials I
think the still a lot of work to be done
to to describe how that could work but
as I say this is testing the limitations
of randomized clinical trial technology
due to the precision with which we are
able to molecular describe patients
using next-gen sequencing and similar
molecular profiling technologies this I
think is one of the the factors which
highlights the fact that trial design
and regulatory frameworks need to be
need to evolved to maximize the
potential benefit of next-gen sequencing
and other therapeutic innovative and
sorry another other innovations if we
think about the evolution of the
therapeutic alternatives which we now
have with multiple new small molecule
inhibitors with second and
third-generation molecular and abilities
with checkpoint inhibitors and other
immunotherapeutic approaches now with
essentially with cancer vaccines with T
cell-based therapies so we had now have
a wide range of of therapeutic
alternatives we have profiling
technologies such as next-gen sequencing
liquid biopsies we have extensive
knowledge of the epidemiology of cancer
and we're beginning to be able to
develop databases which linked together
treatment outcomes and and molecular
profiles and we can see the the ability
to begin to develop a treatment
algorithms which will allow us to match
optimally match patients to a therapy as
I described before either a and approved
therapy or
vestigation Elaraby and our
understanding of cancer in terms of its
heterogeneity from patient to patient
and also within tumors and this link to
our understanding of tumor pathways and
tumor biology and tumor evolution all of
these things have advanced greatly
however our approaches to trial designs
and regulatory approaches have changed
little over the last 10 years we've seen
advances such as a breakthrough
designations and orphan drug designation
we're looking more at active designs but
we need to think probably beyond this to
look at other frameworks and other novel
approaches particularly if we're going
to enable the use of novel combinations
to treat patients and others say to
arrive at optimal matches between a
molecular redefine cancer and they and a
combination therapy we're beginning to
envisage what a modern protocol could
look like the left hand side of this
chart shows the the signature trial
which is being run by Novartis we're
also looking at a potential within
Russia potential model model protocols
where we need to have a master protocol
which would enroll patients and do a
molecular profiling with many substances
subsidies so we have next-generation
sequencing and other molecular profiling
methodologies applied at recruitment
we'd get a definition of disease which
is based upon a molecular definition and
defined by pathways are we had look to
employee decentralized trial models to
to ensure that we are recruit as many
patients as possible for rare cancer
rare cancer subtypes and would be also
looking to follow adaptive designs and
adaptive licensing approaches to ensure
that we we put treatments for
potentially useful treatments in an
oncologist hands as as soon as possible
and potentially open this approach to to
other sponsors so that we can not only
look at and combinations which we could
supply out of our own portfolio or
combine extended care with with our own
investigations of molecules but look at
potentially also using investigational
molecules from other sponsors so as I
said this is the potentially new
potential new paradigm for for
accelerating drug development in this
area using molecular characterization of
disease its enrollment generating data
for single agents and combination
therapy in patient populations which are
divided by molecular subtype and
histology classifying tumors using these
cutting-edge molecular profiling tool
kids and prospectively defining
molecular and histologic subsets a
danger AGG ones that a
hypothesis-generating and have the
potential world registration and we
believe this would allow us to
accelerate biomarker discovery and
registration of novel combination
therapies for these molecular classified
diseases however we see this significant
infrastructure gaps in for if this
vision is to lead to population-wide
benefits particularly in terms of
appropriate standard eight standards for
the identification and reporting of
actionable somatic genomic variants we
would like to see our databases
establish which allow us to
first of all record are the genomic
variants which we which we define in
patients but also record the patient
responses on therapy so that we are able
to match responses to dynamic profiles
to begin to use these data to develop
our algorithms which can be clinically
validated to support matching of
patients to therapies based upon human
molecular profiles and also to develop
decision support systems to support
physicians to access relevant up-to-date
data and to access arm treatment
algorithms to to support this this
matching of therapies to molecular
subtype and lastly developing processes
to allow companies to collaborate and to
give treating oncologist access to a
broad range of experimental therapies to
allow them to treat patients with
optimal combinations and obviously if we
do this then we're going to have to
develop clinical programs and regulatory
frameworks to support these approaches
allowing successful approaches to be
commercialized there's a number of
entire current major initiatives which
are beginning to address some of these
challenges I've got a an overview of
some of these which are particularly
from the European perspective so one of
these is run by the eortc it's called a
Spectre and this is a proposal for a
major collaborative molecular screening
platform this has been proposed by the
you RTC and is beginning to to gain
traction in Europe it has a number of
different platforms and would provide a
platform as I said to first of all to to
screen patients and then to provide a
platform for
multiple sponsors to collaborate around
the molecular development populations
which the spectre program would define
are the many of the cancer call centers
in sorry the Kansas centers in Europe
are beginning to collaborate to share
first of all the epidemiological data
bases of the patients who are being
triggered at these cancer centers but
then also the outcomes data from already
registered therapies and experimental
therapies which they are seeing in these
populations as I said to begin to link
together the data in terms of cancer
epidemiology and the that the molecular
profiles and then the treatment outcomes
which achieved on therapy in these
patients and this has a number of the
canticle Europe has a number of key
goals and objectives which I'll skip in
the interest of time but if you are that
they've got a website where you can
review these goals and objectives and
laterally there's a number of projects
within the scope of the innovation
medicines initiative in Europe where big
data for better outcomes projects are
being developed to focus on a water to
develop an outcomes focused data
platform to empower policymakers and
collisions to optimize their their care
for patients with in this case patients
with hematologic malignancies so I think
I'll with with that I'll conclude and
move to the the Q&A session and take any
questions which you have
thank you dr. Metcalf for that
informative presentation as you said it
is time for our Q&A if you have a
question you'd like to ask dr. Metcalf
please do so now you can click on the
green Q&A button and the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question in and click send we'll answer
as many of your questions as we can
we'll get right to it our first question
it looks like target DNA sequencing
short reads sequencing is good enough
for clinic use but Roche is interested
in long reads sequencing how will you
use long reads sequencing in clinic
practices will whole genome sequence e
be used in clinic practices and what
kind of situation will doctors and
research use whole genome sequencing in
clinic practices thanks for that
question arm thank you for that question
I think this refers to the investments
that wrong had previously made in the
454 technology which is a technology
which is particularly suitable for for
long reads but if you see or if you
consider the collaboration which we have
with our foundation medicine this is a
technology or the the technology the
foundation medicine used for there for
there essentially clinical sequencing
approaches is all based around short
read sequencing using technologies such
as a luminous technology to to profile
patients and I think this is the
beginning to be the dominant technology
which is being used in in clinical
practice to to profile tools
thank you we do have another question
what role should empowered cancer
patients play in helping to evolve the
regulatory process
and thank you so lucky to the next
question what role should empower cancer
patients play in helping to evolve the
regulatory process and I think that's an
extremely good question and I'm I think
there's two or three and very important
roles that patients can play I think the
first is that particularly empowered and
inform patients should engage with
regulatory agencies through the vehicles
which are open to them servers are you
know for instance bodies patients
patients like me this is one body which
will allow allows patients to achieve a
voice but they should be I think very
outspoken in terms of explaining to
regulators and to industry and
potentially to investigators how they
experience our treatment and how they
also experience molecular analyses how
they they view the risks and benefits
over the various approaches which are
being weighed up by by regulatory agents
agencies and I think one of the most
important roles that are cancer patients
can play is to allow their data to be to
be used by investigators bye-bye
industry to inform them on the
performance of existing therapies and
also to to inform the public space so
that the public at large and as I said
industry investigators and academia
where unmet need is available or one may
need is still there and
how they will again how they view
experimental medicines in the space and
are and what what the the balance that
should be a tree by regulatory agencies
look at the next question we do have
another question how can a patient
benefit directly from this technology
can do drugs be developed readily for
that patient because drug development
takes a long time now I think that's a
once again a good question I think the
major way that I'm then if patients can
ban you from this technology is by their
cancer being described accurately and
therefore having the potential to to
find the right therapy it may be an
approved therapy or investigational
therapy for their cancer as the person
posing this question point out it takes
a long time to develop our new medicines
but the most probably the most important
thing for patients is to to leverage
existing knowledge and existing
therapies as effectively as possible and
that's what this new technology allows
them to do to match their their
particular cancer to the currently
available therapies thank you our next
question it would be nice to culture
CTCs and screen for drug sensitivity to
determine the most effective drug for
individual patient what is the latest
progress in ctc culturing
looking at the next question respected
to know to potentially culture CTC
that's great for drug sensitivity
determined most effective drugs for
patients and it's whether or not you did
you so you know I would guess here at
the time that the key opportunity that
this question is seeing is the potential
for for culturing cancer stem cells
which can be derived from blood but
there's a think a key question whether
or not these cancer stem cells are
adequately represented representative of
the the main tumor which a patient is
suffering from in these are all single
cells cancer stem cells and will only
represent a subset of a of the of the
various clones which are which are
present in a particular tumor and may
give a wrong picture and I think the
other thing that we clearly understand
these that the tumor microenvironment so
that means the solid tumor in its
context and the way this interacts with
the are with the micro environment
around it the blood vessels the the also
the immune system and the Kansas Loma is
key to understanding how a a tumor world
will respond and this cannot be
replicated particularly well in a in a
in a culturing environment there are
efforts being under way to look at 3d
cultures which will give us a better
representation in a cultured environment
but now these are still very early
approaches and have yet to translate to
to accurately
seeing whether or not a particular
cancer will respond to a particular
therapy so I look at the next question
we do have another question has the
propensity for mutation escape and
characterized by a set of molecular
targets especially beyond canonical
tumor suppressor genes I can't we the
rest of the course are you learn beyond
tumor suppressor genes I think we're
still in the early days of this and
understanding exactly how mutation his
cape occurs and get a broad
understanding of it but you know we
clearly see the time where there is a I
mean we can model this to a degree in
either in in culture or in in more
complex animal models to get an
understanding of how this tumor escape
occurs and we're beginning to get a
better understanding of this but it's a
I think it's relatively early days yet
so looking at okay I'm afraid we're
coming close to our time we're going to
have to have this be our last question
how safe is it to imply ng s plus
biomarker baskets clinical trial
approach in terms of side effects of a
new potential drug is there a chance to
observe side effects in a part of
selected patients for a trial due to
unique genetic background of the
patients I think that's an excellent
question that's a an excellent question
the
the toolbox that we currently have four
matching therapies to patients I think
the the questioner is pointing out that
I if we simply I think in terms of
efficacy are we we're not seeing the
whole picture and it's important for us
to get a much richer understanding of
not only our combinations can be
beneficial in terms of attacking
particular tumor drivers but also what
the what the potential is for drug drug
interactions for the synergistic action
between drugs not on not in terms of
beneficial effects but in terms of
adverse effects and we're I think just
beginning to develop the toolbox which
we're going to require to do this but
it's going to be a complex undertaking
we're going to have to think I think
more richly in terms of clinical
pharmacology approaches to to support
decision-making here and I think we're
also going to have to do a much better
job of recording adverse events or novel
adverse interactions sorry adverse
actions of drugs in novel combinations
thank you dr. Metcalf I would once like
once again like to thank you for your
presentation and ask you if you have any
final comments for our attendees today
I'm not just to thank everybody for
their attention and perhaps the only
final coming would I would have is that
this is a rapidly moving space there are
important considerations of Public
Health involved in many of these
decisions i'm sure many of the people
here have seen things such as the cancer
moonshot from which is being promoted by
joe biden and our president obama's
precision medicine initiative i think
it's extremely important that not only
scientists but also the wider public
become involved in this dialogue because
it will have an important impact upon
how we're able to defeat cancer going
forward thank you once again dr. Metcalf
very important information to bring to
us today I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making this educational web
seminar possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
and through the end of August 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this broadcast is
available for live replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
when they have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again goodbye